Mentor A: صباح الخير يا سعود تسمعيني.
Learner A7: صباح النور. سامعيني تمام.
Learner A4: أن.
Mentor A: أنا آسفة جدا على التأخير. دي كانت اشوف زوم يعني.
Learner A7: لا لا عادي والله.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي خليني الأول أبريك ده آيز كدا وأعرفكم بنفسي أنا إسمي فرح أحمد
Mentor A: خريجة 25 هندسة القاهرة بس يعني مش شغالة في الكوميكس شغالة. سوفت وار ماشي أنا دلوقتي معيدة في جامعة النيل
Mentor A: وبشتغل إي آي سوفتوير إنجينير شركة اسمها الو أم أنا أول ما تخرجت
Mentor A: دخلت سبرنس كنترن فيها وقعدت فيها 8 شهور يعني دخلتها أول ما تخرجت على طول
Mentor A: وكنا ناس قليلة أوي وكانت فيزيكال انترشك يعني فدخلتها مثلا شهر تمانية تخرجت 7 دخلتها 8
Mentor A: ودلت فيها لحد شهر تلاتة وبعدين أو رحت قفز فلتان،
Mentor A: فأنا الفترة دي كلها كنت ومعظم أخدتها أصلا في قف
Mentor A: عايزة بقى كل 1 فيكم يبتديوس كده
Mentor A: ويقولي هو جامعة وكلية إيه سنة كم يعني يديني عن نفسه السكيلز بتاعته واشتغل علي قبل كده هل دي أول ممكن كده سريعا كل 1
Mentor A: يتكلم.
Learner A4: ماشي انا اسمي عمر درغام انا الجماعة المصرية اليابانية ما بين الاثنين الصراحة مش كده دخلت الانت
Learner A4: اشتغلت بروجكتس بس هي كانت بيسك يعني لحد ما في
Learner A4: كان ديفيرنينغ ولدات المفروض يعني كنت حعمل كلاسيفيكيشن للتاكس وكدا
Learner A4: واشتغلت بلوك شين اشتغلت إشتغلت ويلوبينج
Learner A4: اشتغلت يعتبر كل البيس فيد الموجودة في قصدي الكومبيوتر سايمز
Learner A4: بس في الجزئية بتاعت ما بين ال اي وال سيبر سكيري.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب خليني برضه يعني كل 1 هسأله نفس الأسئلة دي عايزاك تقلي عندك نوليدج في ال اف بي اي وسوفت ويرغ.
Learner A4: بصراحة مش إكسبورت يعني بس أعرف البيزنج بتاعتها.
Mentor A: إلى.
Learner A4: كثير.
Mentor A: مش طبقت.
Learner A4: جيت آب يعني.
Mentor A: أو.
Learner A4: برضه مش كثير يعني البايز اللي خلاني أقدر عايز أشتغل على.
Mentor A: ميس ذكر.
Learner A4: الصراحة ما تعاملتش معاه.
Mentor A: أوكي ماشي طيب ماشي ممكن حد تاني يكلمك ميرسي يا عمر.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A7: أنا يوسف محمد في الأكاديمية العربية
Learner A7: ده خصوصي أصلا حتة داتا وكدا
Learner A7: اشتغلت بروجكتس في الجامعة برضه لي علاقة عامة والحتة دي بالذات وكنت جات فترة كنت برضه كورس برضه عندي شوية
Learner A7: صور كده.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب فول ستاك كنت بتشتغل إيه فرانس ومش طالبة.
Learner A7: فرنت إندي كنت تمام جدا فيها ما كملتش قوي فيها قوي بس عندي فكرة شوي عن الموسيقى والحتة دي شوية بس ما كملتش.
Mentor A: اشتغلت رياكتي.
Learner A7: نيوجيست.
Mentor A: تعرفش رآكتي يعني.
Learner A7: ، لا، لا.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب برضه زي عمر جاته دوكر والإف بي اي وسوفت وير ليرينغ.
Learner A7: يعني مش كتير قوي فيها بصراحة يعني قوي بسرعة في حتة دي.
Mentor A: أنا يهمني بس يا جماعة جت لأن إنتوا شغالين في تيم
Mentor A: يعني جت إنت عارف جات حتى البيزكس اللي هو بس البول والكوش والبرنشن ده بس
Mentor A: تبقى بس فاهم جت هل عندك نالج فيها جربت فيها قبل كده جيت حب يعني.
Learner A7: يطبقوا عندي فكرة بسيطة.
Mentor A: هي جتها ماشي دكر.
Learner A7: لا لا مش قوي صعب.
Mentor A: أوكي ماشي طيب ممكن حد تاني سويتش ميرسي يا يوسف.
Guest A1: تمام أنا ندى أحمد سمير في جامعة عين شمس كومبيوتر سايمز رايحة ثالثة إن شاء الله
Guest A1: أنا اشتغلت في الجامعة على مشاريع زي مثلا ولا لأ اشتغلت على
Guest A1: وقبل ال كدا وأنا في أولى يعني كنت باخد ستريند أكتيڤيتي أكتيڤيتي بيشرحوا إيه آي
Guest A1: فأنا أصلا خدت النموذج عندي من من هناك يعني
Guest A1: بس ابتديت من هناك كبيزكس بعد كده طبعا قعدت أعمل سيرش أكتر وأجيت ديب أكتر بعد كده أخدت سوماري كورس معاهم في الجامعة بدأت أفهم يعني راك بقى وكل الحتطت دي يعني
Guest A1: دوكر أنا ما عنديش عنده أي معلومات خالص
Guest A1: فيست إي بي آي، أنا كنت بحاول إن أنا أعمل بياخد دوكومينتس ويعملها شوكينغ. وهكذا كل ده يعني بمساعدة عندي مش قد كده لسه في الحتة دي
Guest A1: فكنت بحاول أفهم من جد دي يعني بي آي وازاي إن أنا يعني أقدر آخذ دوكيمنت أو كده من من إنت أو كده بس كانت كلها حاجات بزيكس يعني مش مش حاجة جامدة يعني
Guest A1: بس حضرتك عايزة تسألي حاجة تاني.
Mentor A: لا تمام غت إن شاء الله.
Guest A1: أنا جيتها أقدر وبوش و في برينشيز بس كده يعني حاجات برضه مش مش عادية.
Mentor A: دوكر دوكر لأ.
Guest A1: لا ده كان ما عرفش عن أي حاجة بس.
Mentor A: طيب فلوس تاك اشتغلتي فرونت أو بات أند قبل كده.
Guest A1: أيوة أيوة؟ أنا باخد دلوقتي كورس حاليا في الأجازة دي كامب يعني على الفول ستاك اللي هو على كورس على يديمي كده بس أنا لسه في مرحلة يعني لسه ما دخلتش في الباك إند قوي فأعرف حضرتك قوي لسه ما عملتش
Guest A1: انت خدت حاجات بسيطة لحد اس اس ال
Guest A1: أوكي وفي برضه. خط كويز أس كيو ال.
Mentor A: ميرسي. أنا بس ممكن حد تاني.
Guest A1: عليه.
Learner A3: السلام عليكم أنا إسمي مصطفى أنا مفروض خريجة من جامعة القاهرة 25 أنا طبعا إي آي ميتشر والله.
Mentor A: قلت.
Learner A3: إن أنا إشتغلت.
Mentor A: هم بس القاهرة إزاي.
Learner A3: مش هندسة القاهرة.
Mentor A: أما العيد.
Learner A3: يس.
Mentor A: قياس أوكي ماشي جرادو صح؟
Learner A3: أنا كاتب.
Mentor A: أوكي.
Learner A3: و أنا اشتغلت على مشريات كتير إن بي بيس
Learner A3: تقريبا في كل حاجة إشتغلت واشتغلت الانس
Learner A3: ويعني آخر فترة كنت بتعلم القصص بتاعة ابتديت في
Learner A3: كرو آي جريت أعرف يعني البيزكس
Learner A3: وبالنسبة لل دوكر يعني عندي عنه فكرة يعني بالنسبة لا تمام ما فيش مشكلة ان شاء الله أقدر أشتغل بجد عادي
Learner A3: بس أي حاجة تانية عايزين تعرفوها.
Mentor A: بيفولستر تعرف.
Learner A3: اشتغلت اشتغلت باك اند اشتغلت شوية في جانغو تعليقاتك الجاي.
Mentor A: عندنا كله لأنه بايتن هو الوحيد اللي بيعرف فمش مهتمين.
Learner A3: واشتغلت كمان البلاستيك.
Mentor A: ميش أوكي مش فرقين.
Learner A3: بس آي نو ذي بيسكس يعني فيري بيسكس فاست تي في آي.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي ميرسي يا مصطفى ممكن حتى.
Learner A2: محمد مهدي خريج جامعة المنصورة
Learner A2: برضو عندي عندي بس ما اشتغلتش لوكور برضو قبل كده وما عنديش خلفية أوي بصراحة في انا كنت بدرس وكده ولسه.
Mentor A: إنجينيينغ، ولا سي اس.
Learner A2: سياسي.
Mentor A: أوكي.
Learner A2: ولسه محاول على بي آيس والفاس تي بي اي والحاجات دي كده لسه بسيط يعني.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي إنت قلت داكر وجهتهم إيه.
Learner A2: جت وقتها بس لسة ما اشتغلتش حاجة على دوكر بصراحة.
Mentor A: ميش طيب ميرسي محمد ممكن.
Learner A2: اعتقد احنا كده خلصنا.
Mentor A: نخلص.
Learner A6: و.
Learner A6: ونحن سته او خمسه.
Mentor A: 5 ثواني. أتشرف كده وانتو.
Learner A4: ألو.
Mentor A: أيوة أيوة ثانية.
Learner A3: 8.
Learner A4: الزهرة.
Mentor A: أيوا تفضل.
Learner A4: انا اسمي عمر خالد يعني فرنش فرنش.
Learner A4: اشتغلت ب ما اشتغلتش أوي قوي. كان كنت عملت في نرج إنهيل المفروض إنه هو كان
Learner A4: عشان السنتوس بتاعت الكورونا يعني بيسألني مثلا فبيحدد على حسب ال تريندين سيت المشكلة بالزبط.
Mentor A: أوكي.
Learner A4: باك اند كنت اشتغلت طبعا ويب سايت أبليكيشن.
Mentor A: كل.
Learner A4: واه ويبسايت.
Mentor A: ويبسايت ده كان معمول بإيه.
Learner A4: معلش.
Mentor A: الويب سايت ده فرونت اند كان بإيه بريكت ولا بإيه.
Learner A4: رئاسة.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: وطبعا سكريبت.
Mentor A: مانجو.
Learner A4: لا علينا واضحة.
Mentor A: مونغو ديبي.
Learner A4: مو غود بيئة.
Mentor A: أوكي ماشي طيب دكر وجهة حبك.
Learner A4: ذكر اشتغلت ليه بس بصراحة يعني الموضوع كان جيد اكتر
Learner A4: كنا كنا نتين بس كنا كل 1 فينا شغال.
Mentor A: يعني بتعرف تتعامل يعني خبطت فيه قبل كده يعني.
Learner A4: الذكر نفسه. ما اشتغلتش مع دايريكت سواء كان عبارة عن سيستم لي علاقة بقى.
Mentor A: أوكي ماشي لا بس انت دلوقتي بعيدا عن الكلاود إنت عندك بروجكت ولا تكتبلي مثلا.
Learner A4: لا يعني ممكن ممكن أتعامل يعني أنا كنت لما كنت باجي أتعامل مع بكر كنت يعني بمشي مع ساذج.
Mentor A: ماشي اوكي طيب حكيت أنا تعلمت ماشي أوكي حلو قصدك.
Learner A6: تمام ركبوا.
Mentor A: إي.
Learner A6: أتكلم. أنا هولك.
Mentor A: وفي حد تاني.
Learner A6: تمام.
Mentor A: شكرا.
Learner A6: انا اسامة اسلام خريج السادس اشتغلت على كم بروجكت في الراي والكومبيوتر بيجن كنت اعمل زي سامراء كده هوت
Learner A6: والكومبيوتر فيجن كنت شغال برضو على كم حاجة في ديسيزنتكشن بلانت بالذات
Learner A6: يعني عند النور دي كفاية فيه
Learner A6: دكتور تعاملت معاه بس مش مش كتير بصراحة يعني مش
Learner A6: يعني أنا فاهم كذكر وفاهم فكرة الكونتينر وكدا بس ما تعاملتش معاهم كتير بصراحة.
Mentor A: ماشي اوكي طيب فلوسناك عندك أو حاجة رياكتي.
Learner A6: لا، بصراحة، أنا اشتغلت قبل كده.
Mentor A: ممكن.
Mentor A: تمام ماشي خلص طيب بصور إحنا خلينا نتكلم شوية كدا ندردش مع بعض
Mentor A: الإنترنشيب فكرتها إيه إن هي بتحطكوا
Mentor A: حرفيا كإنكو في وورك إنفيرنت. أوكي أنا كمنتور مش حمسكلكوا مثلا أقعدوا أديكوا درجات أو أي حاجة أنا كإني مانجيت
Mentor A: وكيف أنا مش حبقى عندي سلطة عليك واشوف مين مثلا
Mentor A: مين اشتغل مين عمل الحاجة دي مين ما عملهاش يعني فاهمين أصدي يعني كأنها بالضبط شركة وإنتو يعني شغالين فيها وأنا كأني بس الجونيورز اللي شغالين في الشركة.
Mentor A: وكيف لو حد مثلا عملش شغله؟ أنا مش أجي أقوله أنت عملت الشغل مش عارف لا يعني إحنا أكبر من كده الكلام ده كان ممكن يحصل في الجامعة
Mentor A: فدي أول كنت مهمة جدا جدا يوم الحد اللي هو زي إحنا دلوقتي ده إحنا
Mentor A: الأسبوع يعني كل أسبوع بيبقى عندنا كل 1 عليه يعني شوية إنتو تقريبا بعتولوكو تاسكس صح
Mentor A: حنبتدي فيها كل 1 يبص على الكاست بتاعته يشوف أفكاره فيها جاتلي فكرة كده يقولهالي وهكذا
Mentor A: ده مهم جدا جدا أوكي فده أول ميكي بعدين عندكوا إتنين تلات 4 بتعملوا مع بعض إنتو أنا مش حدخل فيه ممكن أدخل لو حد أو أنا ممكن أدخل تشيك عليكم أو كذا إنتوا لازم تتقابلوا مع بعض
Mentor A: الصبح يعني بداية اليوم كانت
Mentor A: لازم تعملوا ستاند أوف ميتينج كده النهارده خلصنا إيه بروجكت في الآخر بيطلع منكو كلكوا
Mentor A: زي ما حنشوف بعد شوية كل 1 يبقى شغال في حتة بالزبط في بروجكت ده
Mentor A: أوكي فكل 1 معتمد حد منين بروجكت معتمد على كل 1 فيكو
Mentor A: تمام فده مهم جدا ليكوا إنتو عشان تعرفوا مع بعض زي ما قلتلكم أنا منتر مش هدفي إن أنا الموضوع ما بينكم مش هدفي إن أنا أقعد أزبطلكم الدنيا وأقولكوا مين هيعمل إيه وهكذا إنتو مفروض إنتو مع بعض
Mentor A: أوكي أنا أنا دوري بيجي إمتى إن أنا أجاير أو إن أنا أفتح لكم أفكار معاكو أقول لكم تولز جديدة مثلا وهكذا
Mentor A: من ديسكات الأفكار وهكذا يعني أوكي طيب دي تاني نقطة
Mentor A: قلنا 2 3 اربعة فضلنا مين الخميس الخميس أخر اليوم حنتقابل تاني مع بعض ده اسمه ميتينغ ده
Mentor A: أنا محتاجة أشوف بقى محتاجة أشوف أوتب من كل 1 على الحاجة لو كان شغال عليها أوب طالع وشغال وزي الفلول.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب طبعا في نص الأسبوع لو حد بلوغ أنا هدخل التشيك لو حد بلوك ياريت يقولي من بدري أو يقول إن هو بلوغ أو عنده مشكلة في كذا يعني دي ما فيهاش حاجة عادي إحنا كلنا تيم شغالين مبالغ عشان نطلع أحلى حاجة في الآخر
Mentor A: وال بروجكت ده يعني من من نماذج بتاعتي بروجكت تقيل
Mentor A: بتتعلموا في حاجات كتيرة جدا وإن هو مش بروجكت سهل يعني هو أصلا ماشي
Mentor A: أوكي فدا أهم حاجة يبقى أنا بالنسبة لي، أنا كحد أنا أهم حاجة عندي وأهم حاجة عندي الركس
Mentor A: والريتر ده يعتبر أهم حاجة لأن ده اللي إحنا بنقفل فيه كل مايستون بناخدها عشان إحنا مش عايز أجي أتفاجئ على مثلا ثالث أسبوع أخر إن كل حاجة بايظة
Mentor A: فاهمين أصدي طيب دي كده ثاني نقطة نتكلم فيها طيب ثالث حاجة بقى
Mentor A: إحنا أكيد طبعا فالإيه أوي البشع اللي حصل ده
Mentor A: أكيد كلنا شغالين باي صباح النور أكيد كلنا شغالينغ
Mentor A: تمام يعني أكيد كلنا نتعامل مع وكلود وديب سيكس ودمينا أكيد كلنا داخلين في حد دلوقتي
Mentor A: بيكتب كود بإيدو يعني بيرسنتاج قليلة جدا لو جبتو أي جيب هوبو أو أي حاجة دي الوقت مثلا حتلاقوا بيرسنتاج أن حد كاتب كود بإيدو قليلة جدا جدا ممكن تكون 20 في المية ولا حاجة
Mentor A: إحنا دلوقتي بعصر والكلام ده ماشي طيب اللي بيفرق بقى اللي بيفرق حتى في حد كتبلي كود بايك من حد كتبلي كود ثاني يوم بعقلية سوفتوير إنجينير
Mentor A: ماشيينغ بتاع الكوميدي دي أكتر حاجة بتفرق
Mentor A: ماشيين في فرق إن أنا أشوف كود مكتوب ناقش فراخ خلاص أنا قلت مثلا أنا عايزة أعمل كذا كذا كذا يلا إديني الكود هو حيدهولك وهيدك فاينل ستوكس
Mentor A: بس أنا من إكسبيرينس اللي عندي لو شفت الكوت ده حعرف إن هو إيه ما فيش أي إنجينيرينغ ما فيش أي يعني هيومن إنجينير إنجينيرين حط إيده أو حط التاتش بتاعته في الكود
Mentor A: أوكي فدي أهم حاجة بالنسبة لي برضه عشان تطلعوا عارفين يعني وعندكوا فعلا، استفدتوا
Mentor A: فإحنا حنفي كود عادي جدا بس محتاجين نشغل ديماغنا
Mentor A: مش حروح. أقول ل تشاد مثلا،
Mentor A: أنا إعملي كذا أنا عايزة أعمل كذا فممكن تعملهولي لا أنا الأول هصيرش أمسكش عن مثلا أبروتشز اللي موجودة. إني أنا أطلع فكرة كذا
Mentor A: أنا عايزة أعمل مثلا عايزة أنيميت
Mentor A: مثلا عندي أو حاجة عايزة أعملها أنيميش يعني آيكون يعني عايزة أحرقها على مثلا
Mentor A: على سلايت حاجة وات إز أطلع فيديو مثلا الأي كون دي بتتحف فأنا مش حروح أقول كلود
Mentor A: أنا عايزاك تعملي حاجة زي كده لأ أنا روحي الأول مثلا إيه الموجودة حيقولك في ليبريري إسمها ماننم في لايبراري إسمها كذا
Mentor A: نسيت ساعتها انت تشوف بقى مثلا الحاجة اللي منهم المناسبة مع اللي احنا شغالين بيه
Mentor A: ساعتها تروح مثلا كلود تقول له أنا عايزة أعمل دي وأنا حستخدم كذا في لامس
Mentor A: طيب ولازم نرفيه عاليه أوي
Mentor A: أهم حاجة لأن هو بيخرب مهما كان هو السلبي الخاص، فلازم علينا ودماغنا شغالين معه إحنا
Mentor A: بس لازم عينينا ودماغنا تكون إيه موجودة في ال لازم لما أجي أسألك هو الفلو مش ازاي تبقى عارف بالظبط فلو ماشي ازاي يبقى عارف بالزبط اللي بيتنادى وإيه اللي بيروح وإيه فلاين مش إزاي بالزبط
Mentor A: أوكي ودي أهم حاجة عشان تبقى حاضرة تاتش بتاع سوفتوير إنجينير في الموضوع أو إنجينير
Mentor A: عشان ده ده اللي بيفرق يعني ده كده اللي بيفرق كان مثلا بيقولك مثلا لو الباي كودنغ مثلا أنت بتبني بيت
Mentor A: حيبنوا التنين بيت من برا أنت شايف البيت بس من تحت مدمرة بس لو حد سوف يبقى فاهم ومتابع
Mentor A: حتى وهو تحت متزبطة تمام جدا وده كمان بساعد في الموديل بتاعت الكود
Mentor A: إن أنا لو عايزة أزود فيتشر جديدة مش قاعدة أجري ورا كود بقى لأ أنا مثلا عارفة إن أنا عاملة سوفتوير كويس فال فاونكشن دي لو أنا عايزة مثلا أزودها أو الفيتشر دي عايزة أزودها فأنا حروح في الحتة. الفلانية أحط فايل معين في وبس مثلا أروح أكل فونكشن بتاع فيتشر الجديدة دي في حتة ثانية بس خالص الفيتشر خالص
Mentor A: وراء الكود وأشوف مين بيروح لمين ومين يتكلم وهكذا
Mentor A: وبرضه من سكيلابيليتي لو أنا عايزة سكيلن باشر ده
Mentor A: حيبقى أسهل بكتير لأن أنا حيبقى عندي ليري
Mentor A: في السوفت غير اللي أنا عاملاه
Mentor A: ماشي فدي اهم حاجة برضه كنت عايز أكلمكوا فيها حد عنده سؤال لحد هنا.
Learner A7: كنت عايز اسال تنزل على الحتة بتاعت ال
Learner A7: فين بالزبط يعني كان في أبليكيشن أو في حاجة اسمها رتب او حاجة زي كدا.
Mentor A: أو.
Learner A7: دلال.
Mentor A: طيب المفروض إنتو دخلتوا عليه ولا ما دخلوا.
Learner A7: مزبوط. أنا دخلت بس ما فيش بس نزلت لحد دلوقتي.
Learner A4: لا نزل خشي دلوقتي حتلاقيه.
Learner A7: أنا فاتح دلوقتي يقولي مش عارف ليه.
Mentor A: حتلاقي في تاسك بورد على الشمال.
Learner A4: هتلاقي في الباكلوج.
Mentor A: حتلاقي على الشمال كده في وورك فلو تاسك بورد و أوفر سايت حتلاقي تاسك برج دي مفتوحة باك لوب وريدي تو ديفيلوب ودون وهكذا
Mentor A: كل 1 يبعتلكم إيه ولا ما بعتلكوش.
Mentor A: طيب ممكن تتشكل تاني.
Learner A7: اللي هي باك لوغ ويك ون.
Mentor A: كل 1 بإسمه دي مستخدمي كل 1 متقسمة.
Learner A7: أوكي تمام في طسك بإسمي المفروض تمام.
Mentor A: تمام.
Learner A7: تمام.
Mentor A: طيب حد عنده أي سؤال في اللي احنا قلناه.
Learner A4: أو.
Mentor A: ده بندردش.
Learner A4: هو دلوقتي حضرتك كنت الأول في الأسبوع خالص اللي احنا حنعملو كده.
Mentor A: بالظبط.
Learner A4: طيب دلوقتي انا ما اعرفش ازاي حعملها هل أنا هديج مع نفسي كده هشوف هي بتتعمل ازاي واعمل التاست
Learner A4: ولا المفروض.
Mentor A: إحنا عشان بس ده أول فيعني بروجكت معمولة من الكاس دي في أول ما عرفكوش معرفش كل 1 بتاعته يعني
Mentor A: فهي مفروض إنها كانت بتبقى يعني بتبقى كل 1 براند أوكي بس عشان ده أول ويك بس بعد كده مثلا في نهاية السبرنتاية، أنا حبعت أناس أبعتلكم في البداية
Mentor A: يعني هنزبطله فاهمة قصدي.
Learner A4: أوكي تمام طيب عامة زي ما قلت لحضرتك
Learner A4: السكوب بتاعي اكثر كانس كلها. اشتغلت كل حاجة وكده بس ما دخلتش ديب قوي في في الا اللي هم عامة يعني بروجيتس ما دخلتش قوي،
Learner A4: فبالنسبة لي مثلا وقت لو مثلا جالي تات ثقيلة شوية هل المفروض يعني اول اسبوع؟ ده هل بيبقى في هنت عنه أو ممكن تبعتلي ماتيريال ممكن ارجعله او ريفنت او كده ولا ربناش ازاي بالزبط.
Mentor A: ماشي بص أنا زي ما قلتلك أنا يعني حنبقى تقسيمة التاسكات دي أنا بعرفها أنا بعرف. إن في حد مثلا عارف داكر كويس جدا ماشي أو بتعامل معايا أو خابط فيه فيعني مثلا التاسكة ما بينه وما بين حد مثلا ما يعرفش داكر خالص لو بتاع مثلا
Mentor A: كان قصدي عشان برضه مش عايزة اللي هو لو حد عرف حاجة التاني ما يعرفوش
Mentor A: يعني مثلا أنا لاحظت إن إنتو كلكم مش عارفين بكرة مش هدفي في الإنتاج تخرجوا عارفينه خبطتوا فيه
Mentor A: حتى لو بال إي آوي فاهمين قصدي، فهو لو حد مش عارف داكور خالص لو في حاجة فيها يعني مش حخليها كلها عليه مرمية كلها عليه بس ليست لازم يهبط فيه، فأنت لو في انت مثلا انت مثلا سايق حنعمل
Mentor A: أوكي فإنت. ما عندكش نونج بس أنا لازم أخليك تجرب يعني إحنا حنستغل حتة إن إحنا لسه في الأسابيع الأولانية قبل ما ندخل في العسف والدوشة وإن إحنا مستعجلين
Mentor A: وهكذا إننا برضه خليك تتعلمي لازم أخليكوا كلكوا إكسبوز لكل حاجة ما ينفعش أخلي حد
Mentor A: زي ما قلتلكم ما فيش أخلي حد مش وحد عشان مثلا هو عنده المولد فاهمين قصدي يعني ده الهدف
Mentor A: كمان إنتو أي حد هيخبط في الوركينغ برامنت لو هو مش عارف مش عارف حاجة في تصفية غريبة جدا بالنسباله.
Mentor A: قصدي. ما فيش حاجة اسمها؟ لا أنا هديها لحد تاني عارفها لا أنت بتتعامل اتعلمها عادي يعني أنا أنا. سوفت ويرغت ويب اشتغلت في الستات اشتغلت في حاجات كثيرة جدا وأنا ما عنديش أصلا مانج فيها خالص
Mentor A: بس فهمت عالشغل جمعت الإيه ال إمرج الكبيرة
Mentor A: فدي أهم حاجة يعني دي أهم حاجة لأن زي ما قلتلك دلوقتي مفيش حاجة إسمها حد عارف حتيجي في الشغل يقولك إنت عارف بريستيك أهلا وسهلا أنا معي في حد
Mentor A: يبقى يدوس في الويب عادي كان قصدي فاهمين النقطة دي ولا لأ عشان دي نقطة مهمة جدا.
Learner A4: فاهم فاهم.
Mentor A: إلى.
Learner A4: بس كنت بسأل لا لا ما تخافش.
Mentor A: دي ما تخافش من الموضوع على قد ما انت دوس عادي يعني دوس دروس عادي خالص ما فيش حاجة.
Learner A4: أنا تمام والله تمام.
Mentor A: هنلاقي لما نلاقي إن في بوينت في حد بقى أو في حاجة إيشو بتحصل أو في ساعتها بقى يعني هنشوف الدور بس زي ما قلتلكم أهم حاجة المتابعة يعني لو حد حس إن هو بلوك لازم
Mentor A: لازم عشان لو حد بقلك متقسمة عليكو فلو في تسويات
Mentor A: يعني الموضوع فاهمين حيبوظ وخلي بالكو ال بلوكينغ ده لو حصل في الأول في أول أسبوع وما حدش عمل
Mentor A: في الأول فهيجي في في المترو
Mentor A: يقول لي مثلا هو عمل حاجة بس الحاجة مثلا وحشة مش شغالة كويس وهكذا نيجي الأسبوع اللي بعديه حد ثاني معتمد على ال باسكت دي هيقول لأ يا جماعة نطلع حاجات وحشة ففاهمين لحد ما لي نفسنا إيه
Mentor A: في آخر أسبوع الحاجة مش شغالة فمش عايزين نوصل لإيه أهم حاجة الريبورتينغ على طول أول
Mentor A: أي حد بس في حاجة برضه مهمة مش أول ما تعطل تكلمني أو تقول إن إنت بلوك حاول لحد ما تجيب أخلاق
Mentor A: بس برضه كيب ماين إن إيه إن الإسبرانتات تخلص منين الحصة دي ولا لأ.
Learner A4: تمام.
Guest A1: تمام.
Learner A4: طب معلش هو ينفع سؤال.
Mentor A: تفضل.
Learner A4: حضرتك قلت وال بروجكت تقيل ينفع نعرف الفاينل أوت بوت اللي هو.
Mentor A: أيوا طبعا لسه لسه كل ده بس نتكلم وأنا بفهمكوا بس بتاعت شغلي ازاي وبعرفوا هكذا لكن لسا إحنا لسنتكلم في بروجيت فلو محدش عندو أي سؤال دلوقتي ممكن نبدأ في بروجيت ديسكريبشن.
Guest A1: تمام عندي بس سؤال أخير
Guest A1: لو أنا حبيت أتواصل مع حضرتك يعني في أي وقت من الأوقات عشان بعد ما عملت سيرش ودورت طبعا وكل ده فأحب يعني أوصل إزاي لحضرتك كإميلنغ ولا على سيركل ولا على إيه.
Mentor A: لأ على اللي هو بتاع يفري ون ده الصراحة هل ينفع تعمليلي منشن ولا لأ جربي كده.
Guest A1: أوكي.
Mentor A: ينفع تعمليلي مانشن جروب ده إنتو اللي بتتعاملوا فيه على طول وأنا بس إيه مثلا حفتح كده مرة في اليوم أو مرتين فبص إنتوا بتتكلموا بتقولوا
Learner A7: هو على الجروب هو الجروب. هذا والله.
Mentor A: لا على على يفري ون ومتينغ يفري ون هو ده الجو.
Learner A7: ضلعوها ترتيب دوله.
Mentor A: لأ مش عيرتي.
Learner A7: لا، أنا ما خلتش علي سنة.
Mentor A: نو أبليكيشن
Mentor A: فاهمين قصدي فأنا يعني أنا حدخل كده أبص إن إنتو بتتكلموا مع بعض وبتزبطوا الدنيا وتمانين أي حد حصلوا حاجة يمنشي
Mentor A: وبرضه ال ستاندرد بس أنا عشان بس شغلي ممكن ما يكونش أحسن حاجة في الأوقات اللي في نص الأسبوع
Mentor A: كل يوم. هتدخلوا في ميعاد محدد ماشي هو برضه عندكم في مواعيد محددة ممكن تلات أيام ممكن مثلا يوم الثلاثاء مرة الأربع وهكذا فمنين أسمعكوا بتقولوا وهكذا
Mentor A: فاهمين أصدي.
Guest A1: تمام.
Mentor A: أوكي ماشي خلينا نبدأ تاني خالص نبدا نتكلم في ال بروجكت
Mentor A: طيب بروجكت إحنا بروجكت هو أو فيديو جينيرش
Mentor A: مش عارفين الفيديوز اللي بنشوفها على الإنستغرام مثلا أو تيك توك أو حاجة اللي هي معلومة في كبسولة والحاجات دي أو دقيقتين خلينا ممكن نقول دقيقتين بيقولك معلومة أون ذي فلاي كده تلاقي مثلا فيديو يقولك عارف هي مثلا
Mentor A: عارف إيه هو عارف فاهم قصدي ويبتدي يشرحها لك بطريقة
Mentor A: أنيميشنز وهكذا في دقيقة بس عارفين الحاجات دي.
Guest A1: متعددة.
Mentor A: ، هي.
Guest A1: إنستغرام.
Mentor A: هي هي إحنا عايزين نعمل حاجة زي الموجود
Mentor A: ما فيش أي تول بتطلع حاجة زي كده
Mentor A: ما فيش جاهزة حتقولها أنا عايزة أعمل فيديو عن مثلا إن أنا أشرح هي سي ان ديت
Mentor A: فتقوم طلعلك فيديو دقيقتين مثلا بتشرحلك وتقعد تعملك ليرز بتاعتها وهكذا ما فيش حاجة بتطلع كده خالص
Mentor A: اللي موجود دلوقتي حاجات زي فيو ثري عارفين ال فايرو ثري بتاع جيمي حد سمع عنك.
Learner A4: اسم تول تاني معلش.
Mentor A: بيسري.
Learner A4: تعتذر.
Mentor A: بيو.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Mentor A: في بقى نماذج زي كده فيو ثري في حاجة اسمها كيلينغ برضه وهكذا الحاجات دي بتطلعلك بتطلعلك 5 ثواني 15 ثواني
Mentor A: فاهمين قصدي والحاجات اللي هو يعني حاجات اللي هي مش حتلاقوها فيها هذا الكم من الأنيميشنز اللي أنا بقولكوا عليه وشرح وديتال وهكذا
Mentor A: فدي أول بوينت الموضوع ده مش موجود
Mentor A: فإحنا عايزين نعمل بقى عايزين نعمل حاجة زي كده بفايت لاين معين
Mentor A: اللي حعمله ده هو مفروض في الآخر مني فيديو بيطلع في الأنيميشن يعني ممكن أوريكو أعملكم وأوريكم سيمبل كده
Mentor A: مش عارفة تقريبا ما عملتش.
Mentor A: أهلا وسهلا إمم
Mentor A: ممكن تساعدنا بأشكال مختلفة ممكن يكون فيها أو ممكن تكون كمان بتساعدنا ممكن تكون شورتيرن أو لونج تيرن كمان بتساعدنا نموذج من خلالها بنقدر بسهولة بمختلف أشكالها
Mentor A: ونحولها وكمان نعملها ستورينج فيكتور فيتابيسيس معاها بشكل سهل جدا جدا زي كروما دي وزي ما هنشوف برضه في الفيديوز اللي جاي
Mentor A: لانغ شين بتساعدنا مع تولز مختلفة فوربسايت معين كمان لنغجة
Mentor A: الله يسلمك
Mentor A: أهلا بكم أول وأهم فيتشر فلانغ تشين هي نموذج إنتيراكشن
Mentor A: بتقدر أكت مع كلش نموذج اللي إحنا نعرفها وكل ده ليسجل لاين أوف كود أو فروم وحدة فعلى سبيل المثال، عشان ينادي على أي نموذج مجرد ما نكتب
Mentor A: ودي البسيطة ونفس الفكرة لو حبينا على أي نموذج بنكتب ثاني فيتشر مهمة هيتا كونيكشنغتين جاهزة نقدر من خلالها نمد أي فاين تايم فبنقدر مع تي دي فايلز باور كوينت فايف
Mentor A: كل ده بكون بسهولة ونعملهاشن أو نستخرج المعلومات المهمة فيها بصورة تقدر تفهمها عن طريق نموذج بتحولها بعدها بتقدر تستخدم
Mentor A: اللي بنسميها بتساعدنا زي فيس و عشان بتاعنا ثالث.
Mentor A: شفته.
Mentor A: أوكي فهو ده الإكسبكت.
Guest A1: أم.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب خلينا برضه كده نفتح كلام
Mentor A: إيه أول حاجة إنتو مثلا شايفين إن هو ده صعب جدا هو يتعمل فيها أو مثلا القشر اللي حاصلين لها.
Learner A3: هشام.
Guest A1: ما عنديش.
Learner A3: كورس يعني آي آي ثينك ثيس ريسورسيس.
Mentor A: الحاجات اللي هي اللي بتتحرك اللي هي والحاجات دي قصدك.
Learner A3: لا، أنا قصدي هيحط عليها الحاجات دية حنشتغل عليها.
Mentor A: إنت مش تبني حديث أول حاجة إحنا بنتعامل مع سواء إنت بس بتكتبله برومنت.
Learner A3: كويس جدا هنشتغل في جلدك.
Learner A4: أنا حاسس.
Learner A3: يعني نشتغل.
Learner A4: الشرب بتاع.
Mentor A: أيوة أيوة ثانية وحدة إحنا مش هاربني نماذج ما فيش نماذج أنا عايزة.
Learner A3: الهجرة.
Mentor A: عادي كأنك أنت مثلا شوية يعني مثلا ممكن أقولك أنا تخيلي للموضوع مش دلوقتي أنا عندي قالي. أنا عايز أعمل
Mentor A: فيديو ليه مثلا أشرح تمام هو دخلي
Mentor A: هو يقولي أنا عايزة أشرح بس أول حاجة كده في دماغي أنا مفروض أعمل عشان أجيب فيديو محتاجة أطلع من.
Learner A3: ا.
Mentor A: اسكت.
Learner A3: طبعا.
Mentor A: بالزبط فأنا محتاجة أول حاجة سكريبت اللي هو كلام عايز أعرف الفيديو ده يتقال فيه إيه بالظبط قالي فده أول
Mentor A: ده أول إمكود بتاعك.
Learner A3: مزبوط.
Mentor A: وبيرسونا وباكستوري وبتاع ده وتقول له ده أنا عايزة أعمل طلعلي بقى سكريبت
Mentor A: تو منوت ماكسيمومس أو ون منوت ماكسيموم.
Learner A3: اها.
Mentor A: وطبعا إنت بتبقى عامله بيرسونا إنت بتتعمل ده بال أب بي آي زيي بالظبط لما تدخلتور
Mentor A: وتقوله بقى بعديها آي وانت تو مايك مثلا فيديو أبوت كاست فهو بيعمل تشاد البيرسونة اللي إنت قلتله عليها دي اللي هو فيبتدي شوف بقى بيعمل إيه بالزبط هو ياخد البرصونا بتاعته أوكي ويبتدي يعمل إيه يكتبلك ويطلعلك
Mentor A: ده ده بس إحنا محتاجين كود بقى في كود انت بتعمل إيه بقى ولا وات إفرت تستخدمه وتستخدموا ولا تشاد شوفوا إنتو براحتكوا
Mentor A: ده وايه وتدو وتديلو ويطلعلك فدي أول ستاج جبت السكريبت الحمد لله
Mentor A: أوكي لو حد واع يا ريت يقولها ماشي فدي أول إيه ثاني حاجة ده أول اللي هو
Mentor A: طلعلي سببت بعدين.
Learner A3: بس لايت بقى نعمل سلايص لايص.
Mentor A: إيه لا.
Learner A3: ممكن.
Mentor A: أو.
Guest A1: هحتفظ بال سكيب أو يعني إزاي إننا هقدر بعد كده باسيت للنكسة.
Mentor A: دي حاجة دي حاجة موجودة موجودة في 1,000,000 طريقة ليها عايزين تسيبوا لازم تستخدموا
Mentor A: ماشي بس يعني عايزين بقى شوفوا عايزين تسيبوا ده إزاي ممكن بس هو لازم يتسيب ممكن في حاجة اسمها يعني أجينت يطلع على طول زي كان بالظبط
Mentor A: فاهمين قصدي.
Guest A1: أم.
Learner A3: يعني الواحد يسلم شغله التاني.
Mentor A: بس دي مش أحسن حاجة مش أكثر حاجة لليبر لأن لو انكسرت لو في أجينت.
Learner A3: عملت.
Mentor A: خلاص حتضيع المفروض من بروجكتوا لازم تهندلوا الحتة دي إنتو بتقولوا لو انتو هتعملوها لو في أجينت واقع كده أجينت اللي بعده خلاص حيقولك فين لا أنا محتاجة يكون في
Mentor A: يا ليتراي مثلا مرتين
Mentor A: لأن عادي ممكن تخرف على فكرة إنت ممكن تعملها كده تديها تطلعلك ألبومت تديها نفس البرنت تطلعلك
Mentor A: فاهمين أصدي فلازم يكون في إيه حتة الريتروي عشان التشيان ما تنكس يعني
Mentor A: دي حاجة اتبان دي حاجة قدام شوية أنا بس محتاجة دلوقتي نكون فكرة عامة عن الموجودة دلوقتي أو إزاي حاجة زي كده ماشي
Mentor A: احنا بنتكلم عال بروجكت فهو يعني من أول لحد
Mentor A: طبعا لو حد عنده أي أفكار إن هو عايز يزود حاجة يقلل حاجة عايز يغير الستاك عايز يعمل وات يفري حاجات ماشي طيب فأنا دلوقتي قوي تاني حاجة ممكن أعملها
Mentor A: تين بلانينغ يعني ابتدي أقول إن أنا مثلا سايق هو طلعلي سكريبت بيشرح لينغيتشين
Mentor A: إتكلم أول حاجة عن هي فده مفروض يبقى
Mentor A: وبعدين حيبتدي ينتقل لحتة تانية مثلا بيشرح هي نيوز كاسيز بتاعة فده سين تاني صح
Mentor A: يعني في الفيديو لما تيجي تبص حاجة زي كده حتشوف لقطة هتشوف مثلا سكرين بيطلع فيها مثلا 5 آيكونز
Mentor A: ده مثلا هي لانك شين بعد كده السين بيبتدي يتغير
Mentor A: أشوف مثلا 5 آيكونز مختلفين خالص ده بيشرح مثلا إيه.
Learner A3: هيطلع بشكل سيمز اصلا.
Mentor A: يطلع زي الفيديو هتلاقي مثلا في سكرين بتطلع بيبتدي ينكتب عليها حاجات فده سين بعدين.
Learner A3: أنا أقصد من الإسكندرية حضرتك باور بوينت شوية.
Mentor A: ماشي بس.
Learner A3: السكري بتقسمها على السلايط.
Mentor A: لا هيأ سيمبلانينغ سيم بلانينغ يعني إنت حتقسم لي عادي ممكن السلايد الوحدة يكون فيها تنين سيمز
Mentor A: يعني أنا مش دي حاجة إنتو صرتوا فيها زي ما قلتلكوا أنا مش مش حقول حاجة زي كده دلوقتي يعني الدنيا مفتوحة شوية
Mentor A: فدي ثاني حاجة سيم بلانغ هو سيم بلانينغ. إن أنا باخد السكريبت
Mentor A: أعمل حيتشرح إزاي حيتقال إزاي يعني فأنا عندي أول سين هيتقال مثلا الجملة دي تاني سين هيتقال الجملة دي ثالث سين هيتقال الجملة دي وهكذا صح
Mentor A: طيب إيه تاني مفروض يطلع في يطلع فيجوال
Mentor A: ده كأنه بيقولك هنت عن البيجوال يعني مثلا لو تخيلته إنتو عارفين الجيسن خايف.
Mentor A: ماشي أنا ممكن عايزة أعمل شيرس كريم كده شايفين صح.
Guest A1: آر.
Learner A3: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي منفتح مثلا يعني
Mentor A: ماشي يعني مثلا أنا متخيلة إزاي
Mentor A: هيبقى حاجة مثلا ممكن شبه كده يبقى عندك سينز مثلا
Mentor A: وطبعا أي حاجة مش أكتب ستروكتور ماشي ماشي طيب عندك هنا ثين وونغ
Mentor A: في رواندا محتاجاه يكون في يكون في حاجتين اللي حيتقال بالزبط
Mentor A: ماشي ومحتاجة يكون في تاني محتاجة يكون في بيجول تو
Mentor A: ماشي البيجوال كيو دي مثلا أي كن أوف مثلا أي حاجة بقى أوف داتا بيز مثلا بيرز
Mentor A: مثلا أون ذا رايت فاهمين قصدي
Mentor A: فمنين قصدي. ولا لأ الو.
Learner A4: أيوة أيوة.
Guest A1: سؤال هو المفروض اللي بيعمل إيماجين يعني إن هيبقى فيها بالزبط هو اللي بيكتبه.
Mentor A: شكرا.
Guest A1: والله.
Mentor A: هو إيه هو هو أنا لو دخلت سكريبت
Mentor A: ماشي قلت له اعملي سين كلنغلي في مجرب يلا ودي تاني.
Guest A1: أوكي.
Mentor A: يعني مثلا
Mentor A: أوكي أنا أول حاجة أنا آي وانت ليرنينغ فيديو إكسبلينغ لينغ 90 ينز أمني الثوم منس ماكسيموم ووتش
Mentor A: تمام.
Guest A1: إمم.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب آي وانت تو بلان ثيس سكريبس انتو سينس بودر فيديو جينيراشن يوسوسين مصطفى تاكسون خبزة سكود ويس
Mentor A: مجمل.
Guest A1: آيكوندو أوكي.
Mentor A: أم إيه ميك
Mentor A: يفككو منها هيقولك بتاع حياخذ الحتة دي من ال سكريبت
Mentor A: أوكي أون ذي سكرين حيقولك مثلا عايز دي بقى حاجات تستميزوها
Mentor A: ده مثلا هو مثلا في الأول هنا بيقولك إيماج بيلدينج إيماجين بيلدينج يعني مش عارف إيه وبتاع ده الافتتاحية يعني ويبتدي بقى يطلعلك مثلا أنيميشنال وهكذا فهمي.
Guest A1: إمم.
Mentor A: أوفن تو.
Mentor A: الكلام اللي فعلا بيتقال ده مفروض يتخذ من بالظبط الأنيميشن زي يظهر الأيكون ده تطلع من فوقها تطلع من تحت تطلع من واتيفر هل
Mentor A: فاهمين قصدي.
Guest A1: أم.
Mentor A: فدي ثاني حاجة
Mentor A: فده كدا تاني حاجة طلعت من الأيديا عملت ويعني ما تستهونوش بالموضوع الحوار. ده بيحتاج ترامب قوي جدا عشان يطلعلك الحاجة مزبوطة عشان الكلام ده
Mentor A: أوكي فدي تاني عملت سين بلان
Mentor A: ثالث حاجة أنا محتاجة. صوت صح؟
Mentor A: محتاجة. صوت ما أنا محتاج أعمل بويست أوفر عالفيديو ده صح؟ فتاني حاجة
Mentor A: ثالث حاجة محتاجة صوت طب أنا عندي السكريبت محتاجة أطلع منه صوت محتاجة أعمل سي تي اس
Mentor A: نموذج بقى وات يفر نموذج في نماذج من من تطلعلك
Mentor A: معايا ولا.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A7: تمام تمام.
Mentor A: دي الوقت معاي معايا الصوت بتاع السكريبت ومعاي سيم بلانغ تمام طيب رابع رابع هبتدي أعمل إيه
Mentor A: إيه أصلا أصعب مشكلة في حوار الفيديوز إن إنت تركب صوت على حاجات تخيل كده إنت معاك الفيديو في حاجات مثلا سينز عمالة تتغير وحاجات بتطلع وحاجات بتختفي وهكذا ومعاك صور إيه أصعب حاجة ومتخيلين إن أنا أعمل أوفر ليه ده
Learner A6: إن.
Mentor A: عادي.
Learner A6: مع.
Mentor A: بالظبط.
Learner A6: وقت اللي بيظهر.
Mentor A: بالزبط دي أصعب حاجة إن أنا لما أجي زي الفيديو الأول لما ظهرت لما قال لانغ تشي مش عارفة إيه كذا
Mentor A: بتاع الكلام مع الحاجات اللي بتتحط وتتحرك دي أصعب حاجة ممكن تتعبها
Mentor A: ماشي طيب طرق من الطرق إن إحنا نحل حاجة زي كده
Mentor A: إن أنا فويس اللي أنا طلعته ده حعملو تايمز تاني
Mentor A: يعني أنا دلوقتي عندي مثلا تلاتين ثانية حبتدي أعمل ولا أي حاجة وات إيفر حيحصل ورد ليفيل يعني إيه وورلد ليفيل يعني مثلا فرح مش عارفة إيه وهكذا
Mentor A: هل لو ماء دي مثلا من زيرو لسنتين
Mentor A: فرح دي مثلا إيه من ثانيتين ل 4 وهكذا
Mentor A: دي بتطلع يعني ممكن تشوفوا تشتغلوا يعني وتشوفوا هتطلعوا فاهمني
Mentor A: فلما تبتدي تعمل تايمز دي خلاص إنت بقى معاك إيه معاك الكلام بيتقال إمتى بالزبط
Mentor A: تبتدي الخطوة التانية بعد دي إن إنت تجمع الأي كوز دي سواء تجنيرتها أو سواء بقى تجيبها إز بيجيز سواء تجيبها بنان وبنانة تطلعها وتقدر أنت معاك أنا عايز السين ده فيجوالد 1 2 3، 4
Mentor A: فأنت تبتدي تروح عادي. أنا دلوقتي لو مثلا هو طلعلي فيجوال بيقول لي عايز لينغ تشين آيكون مش عارفة ولونها
Mentor A: هو قال لي إن دي خلاص إديته دي وقلت له طلعلي الآي بون دي حيطلعها.
Mentor A: أوكي أو ممكن بقى تشوفوا هل في اي بي آيس فري بت لويب سايت معينة تقدروا تجيبوا منها الأيكونز دي ولا جنرتوها من الإم عادي ولا وت
Mentor A: فدي تاني حاجة فأنت دلوقتي معاكي السكريبس تايمز ستاند معاكي بويس أوفر بس مش محتاجة يعني مش مش مهمتي دلوقتي البويس أوفر
Mentor A: يا فندم ده في الآخر هو حيتلزق على الفيديو. إن إنت تزبط
Mentor A: الفيديو والحاجات اللي بتطلع مع الإيه مع ال تايم ستاند اللي انت طلعتوا
Mentor A: ماشي دلوقتي بقى إنت معاك كل حاجة هو
Mentor A: فتبتدي بقى تعملي إنه هو يمرش دي على الياوس زي ما انتو شفتو زي ما انتو شفتوا بالفيديو كدا إن عندك آيس كريم بيضة إبتدى يحط إيه إبتدى يظهر الأول مثلا أول ستاج
Mentor A: أو إبتدى مثلا يشرح هي فابتدي يطلع مثلا كذا وبعد كده يطلع الأيكون دي وبعد كده يطلع الأيكون دي وبعد كده يطلع الآيون دي فأنت عندك في أول سين في 4 آيكونز ظهروا
Mentor A: ماشي
Mentor A: تعمل بقى خلاص تجمع الأول هو ده أنا حطلع 4 شوف بقى تتعمل ب 1,000,000 حاجة ممكن تتعمل كيرت ممكن تتعمل
Mentor A: الموضوع ده أنت دلوقتي عملت عملت الكليباية نفسها
Mentor A: التين الواحد خلاص عملت حاجة كده مسمطة فيها الأيكونز الأربعة آيكونز مثلا في التين ده ومظبوط
Mentor A: ابتدي بقى اعمل
Mentor A: أزبط بقى هي الأيكو بتطلع إمتى على حسب يعني مثلا السين الواحد مثلا طلعلك الترانسيكبشن مثلا بيقولك إن هو
Mentor A: مثلا يعني خليها نكتب كده مثلا أنا عندي
Mentor A: ال سكيب تايمز ستاند يطلعلك مثلا من زيل ولتنين؟
Mentor A: هلود مي نايمز ماشي بعدين من اتنين ل 5 أيام مايمس مثلا فرح أحمد فتح
Mentor A: ماشي بعد كده من 5 ل 7 إيه آي آم سوفر إنجريد
Mentor A: أوكي فده مثلا مثلا أول سينا
Mentor A: مش ده السكريبت بتاعه يعني انت بالصين الكلام ده بالظبط مكتوب هنا مثلا
Mentor A: ده كده هنا حبتدي أطلع مثلا إيه مثلا هند بينغ هاي
Mentor A: ماشي وبعدين في الثانية التالتة مثلا حبتدي تطلع دمج فرح في الثانية الخامسة. حبتدي صالون
Mentor A: مثلا إيه إنجينيرينغ مور عبراس اللقب فاهمين أصدي تأمين.
Learner A4: معلش من كل حتي دجلة.
Mentor A: مش دلوقتي. أنت مع.
Guest A1: هو أنا مش فاهمة الفلوس بس يعني خليك تجاوبني عالسؤال.
Mentor A: ماشي دلوقتي إحنا عندنا سيم كلانينغ حصل أوكي زي ده طلع مشي شايفين
Mentor A: شايفين الحتة دي صح هو متأسيس هو يقولك فرح أحمد يعني دي مكتوبة هنا فرح أحمد طلعنا أودي من الأوديه عملنالهم صح؟ تايمز ستاند طلع كده فده
Mentor A: هو إيه الترانسيبشن تايمز ستاند بالسين ده
Mentor A: من زيرو لتنين و2 ل 5 ومن 5 ل 7 وهكذا أوكي مع مين ولا
Learner A4: وأنا كمان.
Mentor A: تمام حلو.
Learner A4: اللي بيطلع على اليوتيوب. أنا بس بحط.
Mentor A: بالزبط.
Learner A4: أونلاين.
Mentor A: بالضبط عشان أعرف أشوف إن أنا لو أنت طلعت 7 ثواني فيديو
Mentor A: ماشي محتاج إن أنت في الثانية تطلع هاند بتقول هاوي محتاج في الثانية الثالثة، تطلع إيماج الفرح محتاج في الثانية الخامسة تطلع مثلا إيه لابتوب فاهم قصدي تبقى عارف إنت حتطلع إمتى فين
Mentor A: ما حدش.
Learner A4: المنتاج قبل كده هيفهم اللقطة دي إنك بتحط شريط التكست على الفيديو لو.
Guest A1: طب هي دي طول ستستلمها يعني مني يعني أنا حديها للطول الفلانية بعد ما اطلع سكريبت يعني كل سينز يعني
Guest A1: أنا بس عايزة أفهم الفلول كامل من فوق عشان أبقى جماعة.
Learner A4: إنت بعد ما تعمليت بالكلينج حتبدأي تعملي الأيمن بناء عليها يعني مثلا إنت عندك السكن المفروض بتول جملة
Learner A4: فالمفروض ان انت تحطيها في التايمز تايم بتاع رقم 6
Learner A4: فاهم قصدي كأنك بتعملي فيري جديد بتقيسي عليه الكلام اللي هيطلع
Learner A4: مع البويس علشان هم الاتنين يبقوا ماشيين مع بعض بدلا ما يبقى في تقطيع وكدا
Learner A4: أو حاجة متأخرة حاجة بدري كده يعني.
Guest A1: دي على طول يعني في طول معينة يعني بعد ما منعمل.
Mentor A: بينكو وبين بعض أدخلوا ميتينج بعد ما نخلص قعدوا تكلموا وهكذا ماشي.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Guest A1: تمام.
Mentor A: طيب بس المهم الفكرة بس خلاص فده ده الهدف أوكي طيب
Mentor A: أدي كده أوفر فيو عن بروجكت وإيه المفروض يطلع مش إنتو بقى عايزاكوا تفتحوا الكسكس
Mentor A: من على أير فورس ارتيفن وكل 1 يقول لي الكاست بتاعته.
Learner A4: هو أنا مطلوب مني.
Learner A4: دي بي كينو و حديث.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي يبقى إنت مطلوب منك إن إنت تعمل كله ليه لأن كل 1 فيهم عنده في حد يعمل حد حيطلع حد هيعمل حيجيب أسيت وهكذا طيب إحنا مفروض يعني آي ثينك يعني إنتو مفروض جتلكوا إنفيتشن على.
Learner A4: لا.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي هيجيلكم إنفيتيشن
Mentor A: ممكن أبقى بكرا بكرا أبقى أدخل معك. أديكوا أوفر فيو برضه بس يعني سيرشو في الموضوع ده إن أنا عندي برانش مش عايزة حد يشتغل فيه أنا عايزة كل 1 ياخد يعمل برانش بإسمه
Mentor A: اللي هو ماسكها الأسبوع ده وبعد ما يخلص يبوش عاللين ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Guest A1: تمام.
Mentor A: لو في حد واقع ومش مجمع أنتم مع بعض في مش فاهم قوي لحد إيه
Mentor A: حد يزقه في الموضوع عشان يبقى شارد ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام هو إحنا هنعمل خش للمين بعد ما.
Mentor A: مي مش لازم أوي عشان ما يتعطلوش أو لأ ماشي يعني
Mentor A: خلاص إنتو كل 1 حيكون يعني مثلا ممكن ثانية واحدة دلوقتي مثلا اللي مثلا ماسك
Mentor A: وحد ماسك ال أجينت بتاع ال توست دول مرتبطين ببعض صح.
Learner A4: أكيد.
Mentor A: المفروض إن اللي بيطلع من سكريبت عشان يبتدي يعمل سيمبلينغ. طيب أنا دلوقتي إنتو ده شخصين شغالين مع بعض فيه
Mentor A: كل 1 هيعتبر بتاعه إيه يعني ده حيستنى مثلا التاني يروح اللي طلعه لا حط لي دومي سكريبت حطلي دومي داتا حطليفت وات يفر إنت حطه
Mentor A: أي سكريب بتاعته من شاد بتي ولا أي حاجة
Mentor A: وإيه واشتغل عليه، والشخص المسؤول عن هو المفروض إيه دول مع بعض فاهمين قصدي.
Guest A1: أم تمام.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A3: أوفش عن المجاهد.
Mentor A: دي حاجة مهمة جدا.
Learner A3: محتاج نحتاج لتوضيح احنا يعني اللي عم نشتغل بيها.
Mentor A: بطنه.
Learner A3: تعمل جنت بالزبط.
Mentor A: مع بعض شوفوا إنتو عايزين تشتغلوا ولا فاست بي آي، بس أنا برجح فاستق
Mentor A: ماشي ال إي جنت تتعمل بإيه اعملوها كرو آي آي
Mentor A: ماشي ولا أوبن آي دي حاجة يعني أنا في بروجكت جبت سكاي لقيت جيب تي أوف وحش جدا فيها
Mentor A: بتاعة بالنسبالكو
Mentor A: أنهي بيطلعلك الأرز في أقل أنه لو كل مرة بتبعتلو نفس كل مرة بيطلعلك حاجة قريبة أوي من نفس مش مرة يطلعلك حاجة مختلفة تماما فاهمين قصدي.
Learner A4: تمام معلش بس هو أنا عندي طلب صغير لو انت.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: ينفع بروجكت وكده حضرتك تبعتيها على
Learner A4: عشان بس لو حد طلب حاجة أو كده.
Mentor A: ماشي هبعتلكوا هبعتهالكوا بس لو حد احتاج يغير حاجة أو إنتو مثلا إنتو بتتكلموا في حاسين إنتو محتاجين تشتغلوا حاجة لازم تقولولي عشان.
Learner A4: أكيد هو علشان دي المينبونت.
Mentor A: خلاص تمام ماشي طب بالنسبة بقى للشخص اللي هو إسمه عمر جرام أكيد مش حتعطي الأسبوع فاضي لحد ما هم يخلصوا.
Learner A4: لا، لا، أنا حعمل هعمل المفروض يعني وبعد كده بس أنا أول مرة بصراحة فايف لاين فمش عارف يعني حخبط واشوف حوصل ليه.
Mentor A: ماشي لازم تتابع ثاني حاجة برضه ثاني حاجة مهمة قوي
Mentor A: بس ممكن أنا بتكلم كل 1 يقرأ التاسك بتاعته كويس
Mentor A: لو سمحتوا عشان ما حدش يوقف الواحد كويس ولو حد مش فاهم المطلوب منه في الباسكي يقولي وأنا بتكلم
Mentor A: طيب دلوقتي حاجة مهمة قوي في اللي إنتو حيجيلكوا أكسس عليها مش إنتو حتلاقوها متقسمة فولدرز وفي ريدني ريدني فايل تحتيها بيقولكوا كل فولدر وكل فايل كل فولدر المفروض يقول ده بالزبط
Mentor A: لو في فولدرز ده حد اشتغل كروي آي هتلاقي إن إنت مفروض إي يعني تحط ال
Mentor A: بتاعه تحط التاست هكذا ده حاجة يعني يا ريت برضه يعني ممكن تحطوا كل أو ممكن تحطوا كل لوحده سفايل
Mentor A: تاني حاجة حتلاقوا في في فولدر للبرومتس مثلا في فولدر للسيربسيس
Mentor A: دي لو حد مثلا هيقعد بقى يستخدم إي بي أويز وكده عشان يروح يصرش على ومش عارف إيه ويجيبها من من وهكذا فاهمين قصدي فأنتلهم منظمة جدا حاولوا على قد ما تقدروا تلتزموا بالإيه
Mentor A: بالتنظيم اللي بالتنظيم اللي هو فيه فولدر بات في فولدر فونت لوحدك وهكذا فاهمين أصدي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: فدي حاجة مهمة جدا جدا وزي ما البرانشين
Mentor A: أهم حاجة البرنشن كل 1 يسحب برانش يشتغل في الحتة اللي هو شغال فيها بس وبعدين نبتدي
Mentor A: أبص الأول بعد كده أطوف خلاص نرجع عشان يبقى كلنا بنرجع لمين وما يقعدش بقى يحصل في كومفليت وحد يروح يشتغل في كل حد تاني وحد يروح. وهكذا
Mentor A: دلوقتي على حسب الويك. ده المفروض أنا بإكسبريكت على آخر الأسبوع ألاقي
Mentor A: برانشيز بالفيتشرز بتاعتكوا يعني لحد دلوقتي كل 1 شغال في حتة لوحدها حد شغال في يعني لحد شغال في ترانسكريبشن حد شغال في كل 1 شغال في حتة سكرت ما فيش إيه
Mentor A: اللي انتوا بتدخلوا على بعض دلوقتي
Mentor A: فمش عايزة أشوف إيه حاجات كثير بتقام في الطلبات في الآخر.
Learner A4: تمام لو ينفع بس اتأكد يعني من ينفع تشرحيها لأني أفهمه.
Guest A1: أه.
Learner A4: فايف لاين بس هو في.
Mentor A: عنق.
Mentor A: ماشي.
Learner A4: حاجة تحت خالص.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي بص إنتو برضه هتحتاجوا داتابيس
Mentor A: أنا يعني عايزة بسيط قوي بس دي برضه لسا قدام شوية لأن أنا عايزة إنت اشتغلت حد هنا اشتغل.
Learner A4: إشتغلت ده عارف يعني.
Mentor A: حد اشتغل سيكول.
Learner A4: أو.
Mentor A: بالظبط إيه.
Learner A4: واشتغلت يعني تمام في سيكول.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب أنا أنا مش حنشتغل فيك وأنا عايزة أشتغل سوبا بيز ماشي.
Learner A4: هيدا.
Mentor A: مبنية على بوست بس انت لما تدخل بس هي يعني يو آي أحسن أنت أدخل كده على على وحطها في الكود عندك. وهكذا
Mentor A: نجيب.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: أنا عايزة لحد دلوقتيبلز تابل يوزرز وتيبل بيديوز
Mentor A: عشان عايزة أنا عايزة متخيلي في يوزر بيدخل مثلا بيعمل أكاونت جديد فيبقى عنده مثلا إسمي فرح و كاسورد ون تو ثري دخلت
Mentor A: هي ريليشنال محتاجة يجبلي كل الفيديوز بتاعة اللي أنا عملتها وهكذا فاهمين أصدي.
Learner A4: ثانية ونص.
Learner A4: في كل.
Learner A4: حضرتك لسه قايلة مش عايزاه ديكور.
Mentor A: قلت مش عايزاها نوصيكم.
Learner A4: ماشي تمام معلش.
Mentor A: أوكي ريليشن فاهمين قصدي بس يعني ده لسا شوية عليه
Mentor A: يعني لسا شوية أنا بس محتاجة كل 1 يعملي الباز إحنا بنبني محتاجة تكون خلصانة وبتطلعلي أوت جامد.
Learner A4: طيب.
Guest A1: سؤال.
Mentor A: أم أم.
Guest A1: بس عايزة حضرتك يعني مش بس اتأكد أني فاهمة صح وكل يعني فعمل إيه بس.
Mentor A: ميشيل.
Guest A1: اللي هي بريزنتيشن أند بيز لاين
Guest A1: هو ماشي يعني مش فاهمة بالزبط المفروض أعمل ده
Guest A1: بعد ما عملت سينما حضرتك بصي اشرحيها بس كده كلها وأنا إن شاء الله اجمعها.
Mentor A: إيه ماشي أوكي بص هو اللي بيحصل هو هو عايزك تمسكي حتة إنجين أنيميشن ماشي
Mentor A: دي بتتعمل فيه 1,000,000 طريقة للأنيميشن مش منهم منهم إيه
Mentor A: منهم حاجة اسمها لو حد اشتغل دي ليرنينغ اسمها ماسك ممكن حد سمعنا.
Guest A1: إلى.
Guest A1: في.
Mentor A: ماسكينغ ماسكينغ.
Guest A1: ماسك.
Learner A4: ماسنغال باخذ الويس يعني.
Mentor A: لا لا مش مش مثلا مثلا سيئ لو عندك كده مثلا صورة فيها كلب خلاص
Mentor A: الماسكينج ده بيتعمل إزاي بيتعمل ازاي على فكرة ده ممكن ممكن تجربه بقى ممكن مثلا لو إنت إديت صورة عايز ماسكينج مش عارفة هيعملهالي في العادة بتتعمل بس إحنا مش شغالينج ولا الكلام ده إنتو بتجربوا ممكن تتعمل ولا أديت صورة مثلا فيها كلب وقط خلاص
Mentor A: قلت له اعملي ماسكينج الماسكون ده بيعملوا بيطلعلك الصورة عاملة إزاي باكجراوند جري مثلا سودا ماشي والكلب والقطب الكلب مثلا ماسك جرين لايت والقطة ماسك بريد لايت فاهمين قصدي
Mentor A: فاهمين قصدي ولا
Guest A1: يعني ماشي بس مش ماشي اوكي فمدى أهم شيء.
Mentor A: ده بيستخدم بالأنيميشن إن إنت بتبتدي واحدة واحدة تخفي مثلا أو إنت مثلا كان عندك الصورة مش بتبتدي واحدة واحدة
Mentor A: في مثلا على الكلب فيبتدي يظهر فاهمة قصدي
Mentor A: إنت عارفة إن الماسكينغ على ممكن في الحتة دي
Mentor A: في في الأنيميشن إن إنت إزاي تعليميتي في 1,000,000 حاجة في ماسكين في لايبرر إسمها منان
Mentor A: مش هشرح بتعمل إيه بس هي في ممكن.
Guest A1: أم انتهى اليمين.
Mentor A: إمم.
Guest A1: سؤال بقى نمية يعني.
Mentor A: الأي كونس في في حد منكو. عنده تاسك إن هو بيطلع الأي كومز
Mentor A: إنت قلتلك إنتي مش حتقعدي تستني لتاني خالص إنتي أيكوندز من نفسك خلص هادشي غيكون مزلاجة.
Guest A1: إمم.
Mentor A: جمعت 4 آيكونز وأبتدي اعملها مثلا الأيكون كذا بتظهر على اليمين الأيكون كذا بتظهر على الشمال الأيكون كذا بتظهر كذا معاكي آيكونز ومعاكي إيه ديسكريبشن إن هما إزاي بيظهروا
Mentor A: شوفيلي بقى ازاي تظاهرهم إزاي تحطيهم عشان مثلا الأي كون اكس تظهر على اليمين زي ما قال الأيكون واي تظهر على الشمال زي ما سيم بلان قال وهكذا.
Guest A1: آخر. سؤال أنا بس بحاول معاك أفهم وكده كدا وهدور أنا بس بتأكد إن أنا وصلت لحاجة مش عايزة أعمل حاجة ما تبقاش يعني مش كويسة أوي فالسؤال هنا عندي دلوقتي أنا لو عملت لسين سين يعني سين ون سين تو وهكذا
Guest A1: أنا دلوقتي عندي ديسكريبشن أونريشن وعندي طبعا مثلا هيبقى في أي كنز هو مش عارفة هيحط هو يعني كأيكنز. أو لا
Guest A1: بعد ما أنا عملت الجينيراشن دلوقتي. في أنا مفروض أدخل ده على طول معينة يعني إلى الأم ولا يعني حعمل أنيميمية.
Mentor A: دي إزاي دي إنت مع نفسك. أنا أعرف يعني أنا أعرف في حاجات في أنا أعرف بس أنا مش حقول
Mentor A: وأنا كده كده زي ما قلتلكوا إنت عادي قوليلي قوليلي مثلا أبروتشن لقيت كذا وكذا وكذا وكذا بس محترمة بين كذا وكذا وجربي يعني جربي الأب وجربي جربي مثلا واتقر كذا
Mentor A: وشوفي مثلا وشوفي بقى مع تيم عالتين أني أحسن أني تمام أكتر أني فيجوالي أكتر وهكذا وزي ما قلتلكم لو في إيش أو حاجة مانشن أو أنا هدخل معاكم أشوف الموضوع.
Guest A1: تمام.
Learner A7: تمام انا كنت عايز بس التاسك بتاعي اتأكد المفروض أعمل فاهمه
Learner A7: جزء ال ريندر أو ريندر جوبز كيما.
Mentor A: يا عمر.
Learner A7: لأ يوسف يوسف محمد.
Mentor A: يوسف محمد عزت.
Learner A7: مظبوط.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A7: الجزء بتاعي سواء المشهد والصوت وهكذا واعملهم في فيديو ولا هذا الذي فاهمه.
Mentor A: عليه الفيديو إمبي فور يعني انت آخر ستيف خالص في البنتايل.
Learner A7: أعمل إيه صديقتك.
Mentor A: ماشي تجيب ال ال هي الأنيميشن
Mentor A: وتجمع الحاجات مع بعض عشان تطلع فيديو بعد كده تحطلي فويس أوفر عليه بعد تطلعي يعني انت آخر خالص يعني أنا اللي بشوف منك آخر حاجة يعني.
Learner A7: أوكي تمام ماشي اوكي تمام شكرا.
Mentor A: يا جماعة ممكن برضه برضه في حاجة برضه كلكم أونلاين اللي بيحصل بالضبط
Mentor A: ممكن تبعتوا يعني إنتو إدخلوا طبعا بعد ما خلصت حطوا الكاسكات بتاعته بتاعتكو دي كلكم مثلا أو أي حاجة وهو كل بطريقة أكتر من كده عشان هي أنا حساها بيج شويبشن بتاعها مش واضح خالص
Mentor A: فمن قصدي بس ينحطوا التذكرة كلها ورا بعض عشان يفهم الكونتكس إحنا بنعمل بالزبط فاهمين
Mentor A: قولوا له إن إحنا في فارس في أول سبرينت في أول ميغ في بروجكت اللي هو مدته شهر والبروجكت بتكلم عن بالزبط لاين اللي أنا قلتلكوا عليه وبس قولوا له بقى كل 1 أكتر من كده.
Learner A7: تمام أوكي تمام.
Mentor A: شوية صح مش واضحة أوي.
Learner A2: يعني هو كل 1 دلوقتي بيعمل كوليب لل إيجنت اللي هيعمله وهيجربوا مثلا لحد ما كل 1 ياخد نتائج التاسكة من التاني
Learner A2: ونعمل التثقي الكبير في الآخر. صح.
Mentor A: بالظبط.
Learner A2: حنشتغل كلناي.
Mentor A: ، شتالك وياها.
Learner A3: أكيد عشان أنت كريت سبب.
Mentor A: هبعتلكوا هبعتلكوا هبعت لكم اللي أنا بسجل يعني دلوقتي.
Learner A4: يعني.
Mentor A: الإيه بالظبط.
Learner A4: كلها علشان ما نلتقطش حاجة.
Mentor A: إيه ليش الموجودة في يعني ماشي يعني
Mentor A: بس زي ما قلتلكوا يعني التاسترو أهم حاجة تعملوها بعد ما نقفل ال حوار ليها يعني وتتأكدوا برضو طبعا إقروا وتأكدوا إن هي أونلاين مع كل اللي أنا شرحته
Mentor A: بس حد عنده سؤال.
Learner A4: لا، تمام.
Learner A7: خلاص تمام.
Mentor A: تمام زي ما قلتلكم أي حاجة مانشي
Mentor A: وبس وأنا حبقى متابعة يعني كلام أهم حاجة أهم حاجة بجد
Mentor A: تعلموا منه حاجات كتير جدا جدا بس أهم حاجة إن إنتو تعرفوا مع بعض عشان زي ما إنتو شفتوا كل حاجة بتعتمد على حاجة التانية بيعملها
Mentor A: ماشي فدائما لازم كلو كلكوا تبقوا متابعين مع بعض كلكوا تبقوا شايفين مين بيعمل إيه ومين شغال بإيه وهكذا
Mentor A: فال انتدريشن يبقى سموس يعني وأنا بحسش إن في عك بيحصل.
Learner A2: واحنا في آخر الأسبوع لما نخلص حنبعت التذكرة لحد ولا مجرد حنرفع تبعتوه.
Mentor A: انتفعوا يعني هولين بقلكوا بس يمكن ترفعوها بس ماشي.
Guest A1: تمام.
Mentor A: أوكي شكرا يا شباب وإن شاء الله هيبقى شهر لذيذ يعني وبتتعلموا منه حاجات كويسة.
Guest A1: إن شاء الله.
Mentor A: باي واي.
Learner A7: أم.
Guest A1: باي باي.